voter un acte si simple d'apparence qui
peut devenir un poids une pression voire
une angoisse d'abord qui choisir puis ai
je fait le bon choix et lorsque les
résultats paraissent parfois la
déception un phénomène étudié par la
psychosociologue catherine grand jard il
ya des gens qui pleurent qui pleurent
littéralement le soir des résultats il
ya des gens qui éclate en sanglots qui
sont inconsolables parce que quelque
chose disparaît un premier tour
comparable un chagrin d'amour un espoir
perdu qu'il faut pourtant surmonter en
l'espace de deux semaines avant le
second vote
nous allons faire le deuil d'un idéal et
une fois ce deuil de l'idéal fait il y a
la rencontre avec la réalité et la
réalité c'est que nous ne sommes pas
dans l'impuissance
outre le temps qui atténue les émotions
certaines clés existent pour passer à
autre chose la prise de conscience que 1
votée n'est pas aimé c'est un choix qui
va permettre de s'éloigner le moins
possible de ces valeurs même si on sait
bien que c'est un second choix et par
aussi enthousiasmant que le premier mais
aussi il n'ya pas que le vote puisque
d'autres formes d'engagement existe des
engagements comme le mouvement
associatif ou encore se lancer dans la
perspective des prochaines élections les
législatives et même plus simplement
faire une action en faveur de ses
valeurs peut-être la petite action pour
certains ça va être de planter un arbre
ou bien de il ya la guerre en ukraine de
s'engager pour l'accueil
des personnes qui arrivent en attendant
il reste moins de quinze jours pour
surpasser cette angoisse l'angoissent
d'un jour où tout le monde est à égalité
ou un vote est égal au vote d'à côté